i have allison brie with me this time we
are talking
happiest season and brace yourself
because we are talking
a little bit of everything i will i'll
give you
a cat for a cat right now oh good thank
you
you know do you know what this cat's
name is it's definitely
gooey oh really oh i will
asking you a scream question or two
i'm so glad because my husband and i
just rewatched all the screen movies
which had to include
scream four wait now i have to start
with the most important question first
how do you feel about scream three
oh to me scream three is better than
scream
two so i would rank but then i kind of
think i mean i'm a little biased
i would rank them like this original
scream
and then like a significant drop off and
then i would go
scream four scream three scream two
you know i don't blame you i have i have
a major spot in my heart for scream
three i still i still go
i go scream scream is like it's my
second favorite movie of all time so
it's kind of untouchable
but scream 2 and scream 4 are very very
special install i
i fully mean it too it's not just
because i'm talking to i think scream 4
doesn't get the credit it really
deserves
i agree but i'm shocked that you would
put scream two
in that category